il ya un certain nombre d'idéologues y
compris d'ailleurs à gauche enfin qu'en
général ils sont quand même très à
droite ou à l'extrême droite des gens
qui partent au combat contre ces
nouveaux anti racisme qui mélange
absolument tout qui pend semblant de ne
pas comprendre le concept d'
intersectionnelle it et qui ne font
semblant de ne pas comprendre le
privilège blanc et je pense que c'est là
qu'est le problème et je pense aussi
qu'on les voit beaucoup trop dans les
médias alors je prends un exemple à
gauche puisque là on est entre personnes
de gauche c'est le printemps républicain
que je trouve pour ma part totalement
catastrophique alors un exemple parmi
d'autres c'est le professeur de sciences
politiques laurent bouvet avec sa
théorie de la sécurité culturelle alors
le mais enfin il est finalement comme
d'autres genres du printemps républicain
c'est quelqu'un qui est systématiquement
dans le rejet de ces nouveaux anti
racisme dans le rejet de l'islam de ti
qui l'assimilent beaucoup trop
rapidement et systématiquement à
l'islamisme il est dans le rejet de des
féminismes qu'ils veulent qu'ils
voudraient être las le séparatisme etc
et puis donc il théorise la sécurité
culturelle il dit que bon finalement les
petits blancs seraient se sentiraient
menacés dans leur culture par l'afflux
massif de migrants ce qui d'ailleurs est
pas une réalité puisqu'en fait il ya
très peu de migrants qui viennent en
france et puis beaucoup en repartent
mais donc ce petit blanc se sentirait
menacé il sera en insécurité culturel
c'est pour ça qu'ils quitteraient les
banlieues pour aller dans le périurbain
et c'est pour ça qu'ils voteraient front
national et donc ça je trouve ça très
grave et est en fait c'est ça que ça
cache ce tout ce débat sur
l'universalisme républicain c'est la
critique caricaturale des nouveaux anti
racisme des nouveau féminisme des
militants pour les droits homosexuels
et au détriment dix ans à l'opposé de ça
ils vont défendre une vision
complètement idéalisée de la république
et donc ça c'est un vrai problème et
donc je ne pense pas pour finir je pense
pas que ces nouveaux mouvements
contribuer à faire disparaître la
question sociale je ne pense pas
[Musique]